[Music]
freedom of speech is America's most
distinctive right it's a free country
member they used to say that back when
it was but it's also the most embattled
of all of our rights in the name of
safety and sensitivity a coalition of
big tech monopolists universities and
political activists are fighting to
limit what you're allowed to say and
punish those who stray outside the
accepted boundaries
last year comedian Adam Carolla who was
a genius and radio host Dennis Prager
also kind of genius teamed up to release
no safe spaces the kind of brilliant
documentary about the American anti-itch
movement here's part of it Israel sent
me into the Soviet Union when I was 21
years old because I knew Russian and
Hebrew and I was sent in to smuggle out
the names of Jews that I would find in
the Soviet Union and to smuggle in
religious items and so on and I really
experienced what most people in the West
have never ever experienced life under a
totalitarian regime it's a great movie
and if you want to see it in theaters
you still have a chance to do that the
film is having a limited re-release this
weekend thanks to strong support from
grateful viewers adam krola and Dennis
Prager join us tonight gentlemen thanks
both for coming I haven't talked to you
since the film came out to start with
you Adam what was the wrist it anyone
tell you that you're not allowed to say
the things you said in the film was it
did the irony loop come complete it is
interesting when people are talking
about free speech but it's free speech
that they want to vet and make sure it's
okay for them to hear before you can say
it I did notice the clip was all Dennis
Prager by the way so I'm going to frame
I yeah I never get my publicist on this
yeah this resentment is a very big
problem I think it's a big problem week
we we enjoy each other too much we're
looking for problems yes but even even
newlyweds they may sublimate it but
there's there's usually tension if you
could identify
one thing that divides you bitterly what
would it be
he likes gefilte fish and I wouldn't
feed that stuff to my cat no you said
you did feed it five head I did feed it
to my cat like that I asked you
specifically how it went over in the
Corolla home
you said the cat loved it yes he gave me
a jar of gefilte fish yes I did by the
way fish isn't supposed to be in jars
just for your information puts me on
platters no it's supposed to be above a
fireplace in a hunting lodge your
aquarium that's right no wood that's
wrong I think that there's any room for
improvement there at all but the
question of speech do you think the
country's become freer or less free in
the last no it's it it's less free
there's no question and you could
there's an interesting proof read the
reviewers in the mainstream media
not to mention left-wing media on how
they have contempt for the film when the
film features liberal after liberal
including President Obama speaking about
what's going on on campuses but they
they can't even acknowledge that this is
going on when they see the film which is
about the suppression of speech I have a
slightly different feeling on it yeah
well here's what I think I feel like the
pendulum is starting to swing back the
other direction I'm in the comedic
community and I feel a lot of my cohorts
in the comedy world starting to push
back against it because they're at their
saturation level and I feel like the
group that started this thing is
starting to double down on it starting
to really work it harder sort of the
same subject as racism as racism fades
from our society a certain group is
tripling down their efforts to make sure
it's alive and well
or at least we think it's alive he's
right about the comedic community that's
correct outside
that I don't think it's true San
Francisco 49er color announcer and and
I'm not sure you could use that term any
longer simply said in in describing the
Baltimore Ravens quarterback who is a
terrific quarterback and who is black
and he said you know there might be the
slight half second advantage in a
handoff because the the ball is black
and the uniform is black and he is black
so the the offensive line doesn't see it
quite as quickly and the guy was was
said you're a racist and Alesi unless he
apologized profusely as in Mao's China
in the Cultural Revolution he would have
lost his job he felt wondering for that
we know they'll talk where that's right
defensive but the point remains is it I
mean for the what about the people who
are facing this problem in there a lot
of not just famous people but normal
people who are under attack by say the
HR department down the hall Shh what's
the right response for them should they
go through the the Mao's China routine
where they apologize and beg forgiveness
where do they stand up well I don't know
what Adams position is on this but I I
think first of all apologizing means
that you think you were wrong I don't
know how people live with themselves
when they are right and they publicly
announce that they were wrong it's it's
it's so humiliating that I personally
couldn't do it well I think we're going
to have to do it this way because I do
my own podcast I have my own pirate ship
I have autonomy I can say what I want I
don't have to apologize and thus I'm not
asked to apologize because I never
apologized but for guys who do
announcers for the 49ers what are they
to do no I did so it's a horrible
questionable two level what we have to
do is all stop apologizing at the same
time there's one guy with a gun
we just have pull queues and we all need
to charge them at once if we duels one
by one we'll be taken out one by one by
the way just let me remind of it
because is a great film no set no safe
spaces calm and they can find out where
it's playing and I think they will
Adam Dennis great to see both tonight
thank you thank you